en Perú existe expectativa en la sesión
de este jueves que realiza la
organización de los Estados Americanos
en Washington para evaluar si es que
activa la carta democrática tras el
pedido formulado por el presidente Pedro
Castillo quien le solicitó al secretario
general Luis almagro activar el
mecanismo para preservar la
institucionalidad democrática y el
legítimo ejercicio del poder en Perú
desde el oficialismo se afirma que la
medida es para defender al gobierno de
lo que ellos denominan maniobras
golpistas Y esperan que Pedro Castillo
pueda recibir el respaldo de la oea
horas antes la fiscalía que hace unos
días denunció constitucionalmente ante
el congreso al mandatario afirmó tener
más de 190 pruebas de corrupción contra
Pedro castillo y Espera que no se
establezca un estatuto de impunidad
algunos constitucionalistas consideran
que la sesión del Consejo permanente de
la oea podría ser de utilidad para el
congreso y el Ministerio Público para
que pongan de manifiesto ante el
organismo las irregularidades y los
supuestos actos ilegales que hoy acusan
al gobierno de castillo se espera que
tras la sesión de este jueves la voy a
envíe una misión especial a Perú para
que investiguen Y recojan información
entre los actores Implicados En esta
crisis política Posteriormente la misión
Elevar un informe que servirá al consejo
permanente para tomar una decisión sobre
la situación peruana